the IRS whistleblower hearing is still
underway on Capitol Hill we will
continue to monitor it welcome to the
five everyone
I'm Greg Gutfeld along with Judge
Jeanine Pirro Jessica tarloff Jesse
Waters and Kennedy it's called the five
[Music]
the hunter headache getting worse for
the White House the second IRS
whistleblower coming forward and
testifying before Congress right now
Joseph Ziegler revealing his identity
for the first time and confirming that
the Biden doj cooked the books and the
hunter tax probe stonewalling steps that
may have led to President Biden
it appeared to me based on what I
experienced that the U.S attorney in
Delaware in our investigation was
constantly hamstrung limited and
marginalized by doj officials as well as
other U.S attorneys I still think that a
special counsel is necessary for this
investigation assigned prosecutors did
not appear to follow the normal
investigative process slow walk the
investigation and put pla put in place
unnecessary approvals in Roblox
from effectively and if and efficiently
investigating the case a number of times
we were not able to follow the facts
prosecutors instructed investigators not
to ask about the big guy or dad when
conducting interviews investigators were
not allowed to follow up on WhatsApp
messages from Hunter Biden's Apple
iCloud backup where he suggested he was
sitting next to his father
Ziegler also laid out how Hunter was
writing off hookers in rooms for his
drug dealer while partying in LA and
these guys weren't allowed to look into
it
Hunter Biden allegedly falsely claimed
business deductions for chat for
payments made to the Chateau Mar mount a
hotel room for a supposed drug dealer
sex club memberships
falsely referenced on the wire as a golf
membership hotels he was blacklisted
from and a Columbia University tuition
payment
for his adult daughter all of these
items were used to support willfulness
the willfulness element for felony tax
evasion these false seductions claimed
by Hunter Biden caused a false return to
be prepared that underreported his total
income by approximately 267 thousand
dollars and a loss to the U.S treasury
of 106 thousand dollars
now even though the whistleblowers were
called the irsa team Democrats still
wound up attacking their integrity
we can conclude that this Inspector
Clouseau style quest for something that
doesn't exist has turned our committee
into a theater of the Absurd in exercise
and futility and embarrassment there's a
seems to be a new level of hypocrisy
here we are here today
because Donald Trump is exerting an
influence campaign I know the American
people are confused because we're all
confused what we're doing here
nothing this majority has claimed about
the president or his family has Merit
evidence confuses them Ziegler also made
it crystal clear that he's not some
right-wing stooge
although I do have my supporters others
have said that I am a traitor to the
Democratic party and that I am causing
more division in our society I implore
you to consider that if you were in my
position with the facts as I have stated
them ask yourself if you would be doing
the exact same thing I kind of equate
this to experience and feelings I
encountered when coming out
it was honestly one of the hardest
things I ever had to go through
you know judge this is what you're I
think what's so infuriating about this
is what you're seeing is exactly what
the Democrats falsely accuse Republicans
and Donald Trump of doing the only
difference there this is actual evidence
and testimony from people who had to
face the evidence and deal with that
with the doj and the FBI you know we we
learned a couple of things today we
learned number one about the target was
tipped off the night before okay we also
learned that although Jamie Raskin
really wants us about uh to be about
investigators versus prosecutors and
never really agreeing the according to
these whistleblowers of prosecutors and
the investigators did agree and it was
the doj that scuttled the plans to
indict uh for a felony also we learned
that every time they needed to do
further investigation which they would
have done in any normal case they
weren't allowed to do so they weren't
allowed to speak to hundreds kids they
weren't allowed to ask questions about
the big guy as you just heard and it was
all about roadblocks and slow walking
but I want to commend these
whistleblowers first of all these
whistleblowers have nothing to gain and
everything to lose but they brought
their a game and there was nothing that
the Democrats said that touched anything
in terms of credibility and their
expertise and finally you know when you
hear about ridiculous things like you
know Hunter taking a deduction for a
hotel room for his drug dealer then we
found out that Hunter took a deduction
for his father
a business deduction for a hotel room I
guess maybe they were in business
together and then finally a sex club and
he called it a golf club he took a
deduction for and you know when he was
with Rosemont Seneca the whole idea he
didn't take income but he took something
as a loan when there was no promissory
note there was no repayment uh there was
there was no
um you know interest charge it was just
a different way that they could treat
the taxes and of course it was part of
his scheme to defraud the government so
this president wants 87 000 IRS agents
with guns no less to make sure that
everybody pays their fair share unless
it's Hunter Biden or the Biden family
and finally let me just say that
apparently Ziegler said between 2014 and
2019 there was 17 million dollars in
foreign money that the bidens got
um so Kennedy hookers drugs sex clubs my
weekend is full you're absolutely right
thank you so so much for asking but you
know I'm making notes as the judge is
talking I'm like remind my accountant to
change the name of things too avoid any
suspicion uh but there is so much here
and and what really upsets me is this
overly emotional conflation and you've
got people on the committee who refuse
to take apart or question these points
which you know it might be convenient if
this is a basis for prosecution or
investigation for uh an opposing party
when when they are back in power but
instead you know they're dismissal of it
all that means is Republicans you know
they can dismiss anything they want when
it is a republican child of a president
who is accused and you know it it's so
obvious here that they don't have a
counter argument because they wouldn't
be talking about things like Brianna
Taylor and George Floyd uh which I I
think is actually really offensive
because you know when you don't have
facts to go to or you don't have the
ability to really question and examine
those facts then you go to something
that is so completely emotional not
realizing that you know there is no
Mutual exclusivity here that's a good
point Jesse it's like they're not really
disputing the testimony because of the
witnesses and the amount of evidence
hundreds and hundreds of pages so you
have uh accusations of it's a theater or
it's Inspector Clouseau but it's
actually the opposite of that yeah I
used to hate the IRS and now I love them
good for you I I can't add much to what
the judge said she she nailed it but at
every turn they blocked the laptop they
blocked search warrants they blocked the
seeking of testimony from the Biden
family they stymied every effort to ask
the Biden family questions and
investigate Joe Biden
and then we find out this that
this guy Garland lied to Congress and
God and Garland has obstructed justice
so right there he should be impeached uh
I didn't know this but this guy Mr X
great name
Mr X
he wasn't told to go look into Hunter he
stumbled upon Hunter when he was looking
into some International
porn investigation and noticed that
Hunter was buying escorts and Hunter was
using his bank as basically
um an escort
slush fund and his corporate bank
account as an escort slush fund that
sets alarm Bells off with tax
investigators that something's fishy
that's when he looked into it and then
he tried to bring the case to Washington
D.C and they moved the case from D.C to
Delaware and the minute it gets to
Delaware everything goes wrong the tires
start flying off you know the buttons
stopped working they dragged this thing
out like crazy now I just remember when
they tried to nail Trump for obstructing
a crime that he didn't commit remember
they want to charge him with obstruction
and he handed over every single document
they interviewed him they interviewed
his son his daughter his son-in-law they
threw his campaign manager in jail they
spied on his campaign they use every
prosecutorial tool in the toolbox to
nail the guy and there was no crime
there and then you look at how this was
handled
they get tipped off they're told no you
can't talk to this person no you can't
talk to this person they run out the
statute of limitations on that felony
they had them on three three or four
felonies he didn't even pay taxes on the
berezma income so they got to go after
Garland this guy's cooked you know I was
in The Green Room with you earlier
Jessica and when the media labeled The
Whistleblower a gay Democrat you said
isn't that redundant I was so surprised
you would say something like that how
homophobic but you know um they are
impuning him now because uh he was he
accurately predicted that now he's going
to be the odd man out
I'm I'm not sure it seemed like they
were just questioning him about his
testimony they did behind closed doors
and what came out today and I hate to
disagree with it that's a lie I love to
disagree with the table but there was a
lot of new information elicited out of
this so rokana when he was questioning
Gary shapley got him to admit that the
quote vast majority of cases like
Hunters that go before the tax Council
they decide not to charge he also got
Gary shapley to admit that he never said
that Merrick Garland lied to Congress so
that's a right-wing talking point
there's always a timeline problem and
this happened with the Twitter files too
where I heard all about that pesky Biden
Administration that wanted to censor
everyone and then it turned out that the
dates didn't align and that it was the
Trump Administration so Ziegler's
testimony and there are mainstream news
outlets that are posting Snippets of his
testimony not admitting the fact that
the IRS investigators when they were
trying to appointees in the OJ about
going forward were trump appointees it
was Bill Barr David Weiss also a trump
appointee
um it's true he said that he was someone
who shared his vision for making America
safe again so from bringing felony
charges he sent another letter
but at the time they made
contemporaneous notes that are very
important well but it's interesting
because Mr ax Ziegler wasn't even in the
meeting that he's talking about between
shapley and David Weiss where this
allegedly happened
pretty important but shapley wasn't it
and he made the contemporaneous and then
he also today has admitted that Garland
did not lie to Congress and Garland said
that he did not interfere whatsoever
with David Weiss's investigation again a
trump appointment when he says Congress
that he had no issue with him bringing
any charges anywhere that's not true so
why didn't he bring charges in
California and DC that was his choice so
he didn't make that choice of charges
presented the case to these attorneys
and these attorneys
David Weiss is a liar the assistant
would have to give up his job and be a
special counsel but in order to go to
all those other jurisdictions
both cases to both attorneys and nothing
happened all right we got to move on
it's it is interesting that CNN and
MSNBC didn't cover this hearing uh which
is a reflection how they want to keep
this story contained I mean if it wasn't
that big of a deal they would have
showed it probably but it hurts their
sides I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now